اذا عادوا بعد كل هذه المعاناه فستقعه
مذبحه
يخشى اخرون انتقام السلطات الاوكرانيه
منهم
اذا عادوا فلن يكون ذلك مفيدا لنا لاننا
حصلنا على جوازات سفر روسيه
موسكو تسعى الى تعزيز السيطرتها على
المنطقه التي زارها فلاديمير بوتين مطلع
الشهر لتفقد مجموعه من الشقق التي بنيت
لايواء الناجين
روسيا لا ترضخ لاحد ولن تفعل ذلك ابدا لكن
المباني الجديده لا تحتوي على لاجئ مضاده
للقنابل ما يثير قلق السكان الذين يخشون
ان تعود مدينه ماريوبول الى ساحه المعركه
كلنا خائفون انا خائفه ايضا
في سفر دونيسكو على بعد 30 كيلومترا فقط
من خط الموجهه نشرت روسيا قوتها هناك
تحسبا لاي هجوم اوكراني مضاد هنا تصر
السلطات التابعه لموسكو على البقاء مهما
حدث نحن على يقين من ان المدينه لن تصبح
تحت سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه سنعيش تحت
العلم الروسي
مع اقتراب
المعارك فيس على السكان الاعتياد على سماع
صوت المدفعيه